you know I work on myself constantly but
is
is is it playing music is your therapy
is it exercise is your therapy is it all
of it or do you guys also do therapy or
whatever what do you do to kind of calm
yourself I guess I'll go I I feel that
I've learned
um that if I be more loving to other
people that it makes me
better that's beautiful yeah I feel the
same way and it's amazing how you don't
even that realization doesn't it doesn't
happen when you're younger all the time
sometimes it takes you years to sort of
go wow just being a good person is
enough you know just to
to because if you feel like that's
coming to you and it's not like
artificial like I'm just going to try to
be you know it's not honestly like you
don't want to go that doesn't always
work if some if you know someone it
depends you know but I just feel that uh
because it's almost what you want for
yourself or what we'd like to have but
it does have a healing I mean there is a
lot of healing and love you know I dig
it I I like it
Brett
therapy for sure no I think uh I think
songw writing you know writing in
general can be therapeutic I think um
some of my songs that lyrically I get to
revisit nightly so that's kind of cool
to to continually check in on those
feelings and things like that so that's
that's important but the number one
thing I do to to chill and to get away
from it all is I I like to be social and
is going to make me sound like a raging
alcoholic but I love nothing more than
sitting at a bar with friends and just
bullshitting and just having a drink and
talk talking that's like my favorite
world just current
affairs the history what might what's to
come just
gen and then just taken in the room new
people wandering around and so that's
kind of like my favorite thing to do is
just call somebody and go hey you want
to go to smok house let's go to smok
house and get a beer and some cheesy
garlic bread and look at people and talk
like so and luckily I got a lot people
on tap that are like yeah let's go right
now so yeah that's like my favorite
thing to do but see my therapist thinks
that I like to do that all the time and
be around people but being alone is cuz
I don't want to be alone and so there's
some kind of there's some kind of I
don't know what that is but it's like yo
I love having friends over and I love
the love and I love the conversations
and then why do you have to go we're
pack I guess I'm just here by myself
bass guitar you can learn a lot by being
alone like during the I thought you were
going to say dummy by being a dummy
remember that one you can learn a lot
from a dummy like but during the
pandemic a lot a lot of us were alone
you know and not necessarily or with a
partner or not but I'm just saying even
with the partner you know there two of
you or one of you or but we were alone
and so a lot of people learned a lot
about you know you read these stories
like during the pic there were so many
people got divorced well you know what
maybe that was good maybe that was good
they realized they were with the wrong
person you know or you know or you know
or you people discovered things like I
learned to cook or I learned I didn't
know this about myself because they were
all the [__] was shut down and you
were sort of forced it's sort of like a
odd forced meditation you were like
forced to sit in a [__] room for 2
years and not really leave the house and
you're like oh my my God all this stuff
and then you know you either learn to
like yourself or you like you know what
this is okay this is okay to be alone
and it's there's so many things you can
do and uh you don't need all the all the
[__] outside and there's nothing
wrong with it like Brad said that's the
great to go out and do all that I agree
with them but it's also nice to be
comfortable with yourself and U so that
was kind of a weird learning you know
what's weird though is like uh it was
almost okay to feel alone during that
time it's like well everybody else is
also feeling alone too so this is cool
I'm alone I'm alone and it's but then
all of a sudden the pandemic's over and
you're like I'm still alone anyway Ken
back to you no no uh would you say that
you know is is you know something that
helps you for your mental health and and
all that kind of stuff yeah I guess if
I'm um I internalize a lot of things and
so I try to find spaces where I can just
um and this is something I probably yeah
anyway um sitting think sit and feel be
uh
quiet um if I have to work something out
what am I feeling you know I like to
yeah just sit think stare out the window
maybe jump on a
motorcycle um and yeah just kind of ask
myself what are you thinking why you
feeling that if it's distressful like
why what do you want what's going on um
you usually get to the bottom of it when
you're doing that yeah sometimes or I
see the bottom I'm like well okay you
know I'll I'll I'll just lean I'll lean
into my coping mechanisms or how how to
be like um and I think uh probably
coming out of that is either is some
form of communication communicating it
to yourself you know or um communicating
it to someone else which could be
sharing or looking for like you're
you're talking about therapy so having a
reflection or someone to listen who
might have um
you know uh different perspectives we'll
call it professional perspectives tools
um but yeah so for me it's like
internalize and then work on the
communication and um and then if it's
like really like you know personal like
your childhood or you know what do you
feel about your mother or you know
family or stuff from the past you know
if you're dealing like you know for me
it's like intimacy like good thing so
it's like okay how do I work on that how
do I you acknowledge it yeah yeah
acknowledge it and see and look at it
and and what does that unpack you know
but that's a therapeutic process but if
it's just get through the [__] day
sit be quiet maybe jump on a motorcycle
hang out hey guys I'm doing another live
podcast downtown LA at the Regent
Theater and my special guest for January
24th is Kristen Ritter Breaking Bad
Jessica Jones this is going to be a
soldout event I know it it's going to be
exciting and uh there's a meet and greet
and so much fun that's going to happen
January 24th so make sure you get
tickets as soon as possible downtown Los
Angeles at the Regent inside of you with
Michael rosenbom with special guest
Kristen Ritter I'm so excited